PAUL IRISH: Hi, and welcome
to the next episode of The
Breakpoint, Breakpoint
number four.
I'm Paul Irish.
Addy Osmani is joining
us in London.
And we will be doing a
Tour of the Timeline.
The Timeline is part of the
Chrome Dev Tools to help give
you a great view of the overall
performance of the
application from start
to finish,
including all the parts.
And so it really gives you this
really nice, holistic
view of how your application is
performing so you can dig
into the pieces that are
giving you bottlenecks,
whether they're JavaScript,
paint times, reflows, or
anything else.
And we can help identify what
is exactly slowing our app
down and fix it.
So we're going to dive into how
to use it, and the kinds
of insights that it shows.
And generally, you should be
able to walk away from this
with a much better understanding
of how browser
internals work, how it
interprets your page, and what
you can do to make sure your
app loads and interacts as
fast as possible.
All Right.
So first things first,
let me bring this up.
So inside the Chrome DevTools
we have the Timeline.
It's about a fifth tab over.
And it's giving you
this overall view.
One of the things that we have
in there is a Events View.
And this is something that
has been in there
for quite some time.
So I'm going to do a small
little demo on the how this
comes into practice.
I have up here The New
York Times Skimmer.
A really well-done web
application done by The New
York Times to show today's
news and such.
So I'm going to bring
up the Timeline.
And it looks like I've got to
wait for the page to kind of
refresh here.
There we go, that looks good.
Now I want to record
a new session.
So I can hit this
Record button.
I can also hit Command-E.
It's a lot easier.
I'm just going to refresh
the page first.
And now I'm going to scroll
to some other sections.
Hit Go, and I'll Open this story
and Close the story.
So that's pretty good.
I'll stop this with Command-E.
And so down here, this
is the full Timeline.
We can drill into a certain
area up at the top by just
clicking and scrolling.
We can also, with the trackpad,
do a few little
gestures to zoom
in on the area.
So we can go up by
scrolling up.
And we can narrow
our focus here.
We can also scroll to the side
and pan between them.
And you see all the events are
updating on the bottom.
The other thing to orient
yourself is very small here,
but we have a small blue line
and a red line, and these
refer to DOM content loaded
and the window.load event.
So let's take a look and
see what's going on.
The first thing that we have up
here is the blue level, and
so this is all network
activity.
Underneath this is yellow
JavaScript execution.
It's happening all the time.
And then the last is kind of
rendering and screen layer.
So paint and rendering.
Purple and green share this
third thing here.
And so I think I refreshed the
page right around this area
and things were happening.
But while this does tell me the
interaction between the
layers or the browser as it
loads the page, it doesn't
really give me a good view of
what was slow about anything.
It doesn't give me any
good recommendations.
And I can look down and see for
all these events how long
they took and see the general
waterfall events as they
trickle over.
But over this course of a 10
second recording, I don't have
a good idea about
where to target.
So to do that, I'm going
to switch over to
the new Frames mode.
So I can switch over
to Frames mode.
Now this gives me a little
bit different of a view.
One of the things in Frames
View is over here on the
right-hand side, we have
these measures.
So the height of each bar in
Frames View refers to the
length of time that it took to
complete that frame and send
it up to the screen.
And so something that takes a
short amount of time we could
send up to GPU really quickly.
And this means that we can keep
the refresh rate as fast
as possible.
In most cases you want a target
of 60 FPS frame rate.
But some high-end monitors run
at 120 Hertz, and so the
browser will actually be trying
to send 120 updates per
second to those monitors.
Phones might have a 55
Hertz refresh rate.
So 60 is a general guideline.
Most machines and devices
refresh at that rate.
So you could target that.
But once we have these very long
bars, and that means that
a frame rate is dipping below
30 FPS, and that's not good.
So we want to identify what we
can do to make that faster.
So let's see, we're going
to take a look in here.
It looks like I might
have found a small
bug in Canary today.
I'm going to try refreshing
this page and restarting a
Timeline recording.
Oh, this doesn't look good.
There we go.
What do you think, Addy?
ADDY OSMANI: Oh, what's that?
This is one of those very few
times that using Canary might
go a little south.
PAUL IRISH: As you can see, I do
have a Canary update that's
waiting for me here.
This is fine.
We can adapt to this
situation here.
OK, I'm going to jump over
to a fresh Chromium
Build that I have.
That's good.
ADDY OSMANI: Paul, this is The
Breakpoint, so things break in
real time, right?
PAUL IRISH: That's Exactly
what happens.
ADDY OSMANI: So I think
the viewers get it.
PAUL IRISH: All right, good.
I'm glad.
Now we should be good here.
Yeah, this is looking
pretty sharp.
Nice.
We're going to scroll
up to this page.
Oh, I have not saved anything.
OK, good.
And I'll open up this
story, or not.
All right.
So now we've navigated around.
We've recorded a timeline.
If I Zoom in on the DevTools,
you can just Command-Plus to
always do that.
We have a look.
And like I said, any tall bar
gives an indication that
things are not running as
smooth as possible.
Especially, when I was
navigating between these
sections over here on the
right-hand side, it took a
little time for that transition
to visually happen
and for it just to complete.
So I was sitting there
waiting a little bit.
So I want to find out
what's going on.
my tab did cash.
And that's OK, because right now
I'm just really interested
in what's going on down
at the bottom here.
So if I scroll down
a little bit--
ah, my crash tab broke
more things.
Oh, this is trouble.
OK.
All right.
I think we're good now.
Let's hope.
All right, so now we have
a Timeline trace.
The colors that I mentioned
before still apply here.
And so this frame, for
instance, took 88
milliseconds.
88 milliseconds is a long
time for a frame.
If we're keeping with 60 FPS,
then each frame is a short
16.6 milliseconds.
That's our target.
And when we take longer than
that, then we're holding up
the user from seeing that
content quickly.
So inside this 80 milliseconds
frame, we have this long
function call coming
from SoloSource.
And let's look into what's
going on inside that.
So it looks like there's all
these small parse events, and
there's a big, big waterfall
of parsing.
Now parsing here in Thailand
is just parsing HTML.
Let me show exactly what's
going on here.
Now, I can hover over this and
see actually a trace of why
we're now parsing.
And it looks like we're inside
of extend HTML5.
So this is probably the HTML
method inside jQuery.
But it was initially called
somewhere in the application
source called Section
Layout Markup, Cash
Callback Kindle Response.
So you see the traversal
from New York Times
Skimmer calling jQuery.
Now the cool thing is I can
click into here and OK, yeah,
it's going to lend 17 of jQuery,
minify jQuery, not
very useful to me
Now, if I click the Pretty Print
to get a Pretty Print
jQuery, and i can hum back the
timeline, you see that my line
number here is now updated.
So now I can actually click on
line 2185, go to the new
pretty printed line.
If I scroll over a little bit,
you're going to see this
innerHTML setting.
So here's exactly where the
innerHTML on this element is
being set, and that's why
we're calling a parse.
And it looks like what
happened is we had a
succession of about 60 or so
sequential instantiations of
the HTML5 parsing algorithm.
In total, it adds up to about 62
milliseconds, which took a
decent amount of time.
Now, let me see, I want to
see if we can have-- yes.
So there was a small little
hiccup here that we probably
could have avoided.
So we're parsing HTML, then
we recalc style here.
And then we parse some more.
We recalc style, we layout,
and we paint.
And so recalculation of styles
is taking all the styles in
style sheets, in the browser's
user agent style sheet, any
inland styles, figuring out
what the computed style of
every DOM element on the
page is against what
the current DOM is.
And now, it looks like we
have to do that twice.
Go back to parsing HTML, and
then do that all over again.
So it's probably likely that
we actually did not need to
force this recalc style.
The cool thing now is that we
can just hover on recalc style
and see exactly why these
styles were necessary.
So it looks like the cells
were both invalidated and
every calculation was forced.
And we can see why exactly
this is happening now.
So the styles were invalidated
because on line 846 a class
name was set.
And any time a DOM
changes, then the
current DOM is discarded.
We need to find out new
styles for that.
The other one is the style
recalculation was forced.
Here inside line 655, we asked
for offset height.
And asking for offset height
basically says hold up
browser, I know you're busy, but
I need this number, and it
needs to be correct.
So anything that you're doing,
you need to pause and give me
this number and make sure
that it's correct.
So even if you're asking for
offset height and then the
second after you're setting some
HTML it's going to like
freeze everything, recalculate
all the styles, which is going
to pause the browser for a
little bit, give you this
number, and then it can continue
on with the amount of
work that it was doing.
So there's a few properties
that do this.
The other place you
can go to is Tony
Gentilcore, trigger, layout.
Tony Gentilcore is an engineer
on the Chrome team.
And he has a great blog post on
this where he just searched
the web kit source for all the
properties and methods that
will force a reflow or a layout,
which in turn forces
styles to be recalced.
So inside here is all of them,
and offset height and offset
width are in here as well.
Addy, is this making
sense so far?
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah.
It looks good so far.
PAUL IRISH: All right.
We're going to keep going.
So what happened here is we ask
for these offset heights,
and then we went right back
into parsing our HTML.
We probably could have avoided
these two pauses and just
continued on.
A lot of times there'll be a
sequence of things where we're
setting into the DOM and then
you're requesting things like
offset height, offset
width, and then
you go back to setting.
And a good way to speed up the
page is to make sure you do
sets in a row and then
gets in a row.
So eventually, when we finish
this big sequence, we recalc
style again.
We lay it out.
So we lay out the geometry of
the page and how actually all
the boxes are going
to lay out.
And then we paint.
And here, we can actually just
see a little overlay of the
area that was painted.
And it's a little bit
off because I
was resizing my DevTools.
But the main content section I
got painted followed by the
right navigation.
And so that's just the story
of that single frame being
computed and being sent
up to the GPU.
But this thing can
happen a lot.
So I'm going to look
for something else.
Here's another big frame
at 60 milliseconds.
And here, instead of a lot of
HTML parsing cost, we actually
had a good amount
of paint cost.
And paint cost can be a little
tricky to debug.
So here we're just going
to open up this guy
and see what we have.
That's pretty interesting.
This top area got painted.
And inside here, we have
an image decode.
So these image decodes we're
actually added somewhat
recently to the Chrome
DevTools.
I don't think you'll see
them in Stable, but
you see them in Canary.
In this case we were just taking
a JPEG and decoding it
from JPEG into bitmap.
And it took a good 20
milliseconds to do that, which
is a surprisingly long time.
Another thing that is
essentially captured inside
this paint, and right now it's a
small bug that we're fixing,
is imagery sizing.
So in this case, we had a lot
of images that came in like,
let's say this one.
A lot of the source images
that were used in this
application came in at their
native size of 1024 pixels
wide or 600 pixels wide, and
they're just scaled to fit in
the area where they
should fit.
A lot of times this
is necessary.
And there's not much way
you can get around it.
But the actual cost of doing
that resizing is something
that we're now able to see.
So typically, an image decode
is always followed by an
imagery size.
ADDY OSMANI: Suppose the
suggestion there that people
use prescaled images.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
That is pretty much
the suggestion.
If you can definitely serve up
images that are scaled to the
correct resolution, the page is
going to load a lot faster,
and scrolling speed is also
going to be a lot faster
because images are decoded
lazily based on when the user
needs to see them.
So we're not going to decode the
entire page worth even if
none of it's visible.
So it's going to really speed up
scrolling and also speed up
something like this.
The other thing I should mention
is that in Chrome,
image decoding right now does
operate on the main thread.
So we have to wait for this
image to decode before we can
run any JavaScript
for instance.
That's the current
state of things.
Although, that's improving.
And we actually expect industry
codes to have an off
thread very soon, which is going
to speed up things quite
considerably.
So serve images scaled to the
resolution that you need them
at, and watch this area.
Now, it looks like, yeah, we
painted this area up top.
And sometimes with a view that
is not changing so much, we
can actually keep track and
identify which image it is and
where it was located.
But in this case, because the
app has been moved around a
bit, it's a bit trickier.
So overall, this is the way that
we can diagnose what's
going on with the application
from a performance perspective
and figure it out.
And the thing that I also want
to point out here is that in
the past when something operates
pretty slow, people
normally dive into fiber of
the profiler or the CPU
profiler over here, and just
start recording and
identifying JavaScript that
is taking a long time.
But what we end up seeing in
this timeline trace is that
actually there's
a lot of cost.
A lot of the time that's taking
the browser a little
bit of pause in delivering this
content to the user is
not JavaScript.
And so I recommend to use the
timeline to record a session
of any slow interaction.
Then identify what's going
on inside there.
Maybe you do have really big
yellow spikes, but those
yellow spikes might just be a
bunch of HTML settings or
something else.
So this is a good way to
identify where exactly your
bottleneck is.
Is it in script or is it just
completely in rendering costs.
So this is a good way to
prioritize exactly what your
performance costs are.
I think I got a pretty decent
coverage on that.
ADDY OSMANI: I think
you've got some
great coverage in there.
PAUL IRISH: All right.
I wanted to see if there's
anything else
that I should mention.
No, I think that's good.
One thing I did want to show
real quickly is a new
experimental part that we're
playing with inside Chrome.
And this is not yet available
for everyone, but we want to
see what you guys think of it.
I went through and looked at
some of the properties that
are normally a little
bit slow.
They can be slow in CSS.
And I present this list with
a lot of hesitation.
Things that are slow now may
not be the things that are
still in the future.
So do not take these as
guidelines or advice on what
to avoid, more just like this
is a snapshot of the current
present state.
But the key here is to always
test for yourself because my
bottlenecks are not
your bottlenecks.
For instance, Box Shadow is
kind of known as something
that's quite slow, at desktop
and on mobile.
And I'm going to show you a
little bit about how to
actually see that now with
this experimental future.
So I'm going to come over
to this little demo.
And in this demo, as I scroll
the page, I have a few dancing
Chrome logos.
But I can also add this check
box, which adds in some CSS
gradients in there and
some box shadow.
Now, if I record a timeline of
this section, this page, and I
make it dance a little bit,
you can see that--
I'm narrowing that focus
a little bit.
You can see that I just have
really long pain times, 25
milliseconds just to paint.
Those are considerable.
And I don't really have a good
idea on what is involved here.
So what we can do actually
to identify exactly what
components are contributing to
this longer paint time is we
can turn on this new feature
called force repainting.
So now it might be a little
tough to see, but in the top
right corner, I have both a
meter that represents my
current frames per second and
also a rate of the paint rate.
And what this mode is actually
doing is force
repainting all the time.
Normally, the browser only
paints when it has to, but
this mode just says just keep
painting, just keep painting,
because we want to be able to
measure things and we're going
to change this situation.
ADDY OSMANI: Paul, if you're
constantly repeating, is that
something that's reflected in
the DevTools as well, like in
the timeline.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, exactly.
So if I just turn this on, I'm
not touching anything, it's
just like--
ADDY OSMANI: Wow!
PAUL IRISH: --paint, paint,
paint, paint paint, paint.
So there's no reason
that you'd need
this as a user certainly.
But as a developer, you're able
to just replicate heavy
painting situations
repeatedly.
And this enables you to
try some things out.
So I'll actually, you know what,
I'll try and keep this
timeline on.
And I'm going to come
over to Elements.
I'm going to Select
this image.
And I'm going to turn off
this CSS gradient.
And I'm going to turn up
this background size,
and this box shadow.
Now I'm going to come
back to timeline.
Yeah, that should be a big,
dramatic difference.
Nice.
So we go from pretty long
paint sizes down
to very short ones.
And over in the top right we
have this paint rate meter,
which is telling me
the million--
right now I'm painting about 220
million pixels per second.
But when I have, let's see,
all the costly effects on,
that dives down to about 35.
So this is a pretty big
jump from 35 to 220.
So we're able to identify
exactly just by toggling
things on and off what's
contributing to paint times.
Maybe it's individuals styles.
In a lot of websites, there's
a very large div with a box
shadow around it.
And you can toggle things off,
apply display, none, or
visibility hidden to them.
See what the result is in
this mode or over in
timeline paint length.
And then identify where
this is going.
In the future that might be
something like a report, a
profiling report, where we can
identify by element, by style
what's contributing to paint.
It's a little tricky because
these things are additive, but
for now, this is a great tool to
identify what is going on.
How that's sound?
ADDY OSMANI: That sounds
pretty cool.
PAUL IRISH: Cool.
ADDY OSMANI: So do you see when
people are developing
applications that are complex
and have rich animations, do
you see them actually making
perhaps design decisions based
on what some of this
is reporting back?
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
So it's a little trickier.
So clearly, the fastest
situation here is just get rid
box shadow, get rid of CSS
gradients and box background
size et cetera.
If you don't have any CSS, it's
going to be really fast.
But that's not feasible.
So there's a few ways
to deal with this.
In diagnosing long paints,
like I said, we can just
Display-None to remove it out
of the geometry of the page,
and it won't contribute
to layout at all.
With Visibility-hidden, it won't
contribute to paint.
So we can just toggle entire
elements off and on like this.
We measure it with either a
timeline recording like I
showed or this new experimental
mode, which we
hope to be able to share
in a public build soon.
And then just identify
and iterate.
Now if there is a situation like
you're asking about where
it is bad, what do you do, you
can Remove Styles, you can try
and simplify some of the styles
maybe you don't need a
60 pixel blur on your box shadow
with like 0.2 alpha and
you could actually just change
it to be able to smaller and
harder alpha.
Talk with your designer and
identify a different sort of
interaction frame.
Let's say we had a modal alert
coming up, now I can't imagine
the situation where you would
animate a box shadow from
being really big into small.
And that would look cool.
But a much faster way of doing
this is doing a 2D transform
with translate just to scale it
in from the top right and
have a little bit of bounce.
That's going to sit
on the GPU.
Be really, really fast.
So there's some situations where
you can kind of work
with your designer to find a new
style of interaction that
works a lot better.
And lastly, I know this is not
cool at all to say, but you
can use images instead
of using CSS.
ADDY OSMANI: Oh my god.
PAUL IRISH: I said it.
That was terrible.
So gradients or box shadow,
border image can work.
So look into it.
This is not like a guarantee
that images are
always faster than CSS.
But it's something that you want
to try out especially, if
you're measuring things and
identifying that these are
your bottlenecks and this is
possibly something to fix.
You always want to measure
before and after to identify
is this really worth
it, maybe not.
So that's essentially
what we can do.
Addy, can you talk a little bit
about another part of the
timeline that I didn't get to?
ADDY OSMANI: Sure.
So we're going to be talking
about Memory mode.
Paul talked about Events and
he talked about Frames.
But Memory mode is really cool
because it gives you an
overview of your application's
memory usage over time.
It can help you diagnose whether
some of the initial
symptoms about whether you
might have a memory link.
So Paul has just opened
up a little demo
application we have.
And we're going to switch over
to the Memory Paint.
Now this application
is quite simple.
The Idea is that you scroll
through it, and it will keep
displaying new images.
And when you click on an image,
it will display a
larger version of it.
We've got a clear timeline,
let's record a new session and
perform some actions.
So as you can see, our timeline
is populating.
Can we click on some of those
images just to see
what impact that has?
Awesome.
Let's stop that.
So cool.
Again, in the top view, you've
got your Summary view.
And in the bottom, you've
got a Details view.
And in the Summary view, you'll
notice the memory usage
increasing as you move between
the different parts of your
applications.
The light-blue area represents
the amount of memory being
used by your app at
a particular time.
And the remaining white area
represents the total amount of
allocated memory that
you've got.
And this is quite normal.
This type of a curve is actually
quite normal because
garbage collection is going to
be happening during the course
of all the interactions.
And v8, the JavaScript engine
being used by Chrome, is going
to be running rounds of garbage
collection when your
app is idle.
Now, taking a look at the
Details view, which is one at
the very bottom, you can see
we've got some sort of curve.
Now a few cycles after garbage
collection, ideally your
memory profile, so that
curve, should be going
a little bit flat.
And if it's constantly going up
between different garbage
collection cycles, you might
have a memory leak.
That's a problem.
Now going back to the Summary
view at the very top, another
way that you can tell that there
might be a problem is if
you see a sawtooth.
Now, that basically represents
the cost of doing
business in your app.
So let's say that you were using
RequestAnimationFrame,
that might give you a little
bit of garbage.
But it's the steepness of your
curve that you need to keep an
eye on, because if that curve is
really steep, it means that
you're generating a
lot of garbage.
Similarly, in the Details view,
if you've got a STUFF
function, that is also
a sign that you might
have a memory leak.
On the next episode, we're
going to be talking you
through a tool called
the Heap Profiler.
It will actually help you use
some of this information to go
and dig down and find out
exactly what is causing the
memory leak and how you can
go and you can fix it.
Now, one thing that I missed
out on, if we go back to
Timeline very quickly and take
a look at the left, is there
are three pieces of information
on the left.
We've got the Document Count,
the Dome Node account, and the
Event Listener account.
Now, the DOM Node count shows
the number of created DOM
nodes that are still being
held in memory.
And the others represent the
same for your Event Listeners
and your Document instances,
like your IFrames.
And the Timeline view allows you
to filter down on these.
So if you wanted to, for
example, just display the DOM
Node counts, you could just
deselect the other options as
Paul has just shown you.
Just like any of the other
panels, you can select a range
in your Summary view and drill
down to more specific pieces
of information.
And hopefully, on the next
episode, we're going to show
you how you can take this
information that might suggest
you have a memory leak and
actually help you fix it.
PAUL IRISH: Nice.
OK.
So one last thing I just want
to show real quick, which is
that for all these things we
can improve the situation,
especially on this machine.
This is a very recent machine.
And I can get 60 FPS or I could
kill my memory leaks,
but what about on a
mobile situation.
Now let's handle that.
So I want to show
this real quick.
So what I have on my phone
right here is I have an
instance of New York Times
Skimmer running
on Carbon on Android.
And I also have my Chrome
here connected to
remote debug that instance.
It looks like I need
to refresh this.
Come back.
There we go.
Nice.
All right.
So now I'm remote debugging
my Chrome on Android.
And what I'm going to do is
very similar to before.
Oh, it's this guy.
You might not be able to get
to see this unfortunately.
ADDY OSMANI: I imagine
it looks very cool.
PAUL IRISH: It looks so cool.
Oh.
All right, here we go.
Great, so it's a little hard
to see in this situation.
But I'm just navigating the
sections up and down before
like I was on the desktop.
And we're able to see down
here a similar situation.
But the difference is that what
the events actually show
is that whereas before, remember
I had that very long
sequence of parse events
that took about 60
milliseconds on desktop.
On the mobile situation, that
exact same sequences taken
around 250 milliseconds.
So it gives you a little bit
of context as far as even
though you take care of an
optimization on desktop, you
really have to think
about what the
cost is here on mobile.
And I'm really excited about
these tools telling a much
richer story about how exactly
things are taking what are
your costs and expense of
operations on a mobile device
where the story is much more
different than what you're
used to on desktop.
So I guess, again, to wrap up,
Timeline gives a great overall
view of the picture and allows
you to dive into exactly what
is causing you costs.
A lot of these features that I
showed and that Addy showed
are in the Canary version
of Chrome that can run
side-by-side with Stable.
We recommend trying that out.
But they're making their way
to Stable very quickly.
And so that's about it.
ADDY OSMANI: Awesome.
So just take a look
at the questions
we've got real quick.
[? Tinta Suresh ?]
from New Delhi asks, "some
features in CSS3 are still
developing, and they're slow.
If RequestAnimationFrame is
used, will it affect the
performance of map?"
PAUL IRISH: What was the
last part of that?
ADDY OSMANI: If
RequestAnimationFrame is used
instead, will it affect the
performance of map?
PAUL IRISH: Yes.
Good question.
Yeah, there's a great
answer to this.
You're probably used to doing
something like animating with
jQuery an element from
left to right.
And so you'll grab the Element
in jQuery and you'll say
animate and give it a pixel
offset and give it a speed.
And so what that is actually
doing is just running a set
timeout loop to operate about
every 10 milliseconds to
change the inline style.
Now instead, you can use
something like the jQuery
RequestAnimationFrame plug-in
that just swaps in the
animation internals.
It was written by a jQuery Core
Development team member.
It swaps in the animation
internals to use
RequestAnimationFrame instead.
The impact that this has
is pretty significant.
With a 10 milliseconds set
timeout, which is how jQuery
normally does it, you end
up missing frames.
So if we're shooting to have a
new frame available to the GPU
60 times a second, giving the
browser something new every 10
milliseconds does not
synchronize up well with
[INAUDIBLE], the screen
expecting
60 changes per second.
And so about half of the
frames that jQuery is
generating by way of setting
an inline style never even
make it to the screen,
which is bad.
You're doing all the work
and the users is
not getting the payoff.
And so things can be
a lot less smooth.
So always use
RequestAnimationFrame,
certainly if you're doing Canvas
or WebGL, but if you're
doing any sort of DOM animation,
like changing
inline styles.
And if you're doing any
scrolling parallax situations
where as you scroll positions
are kind of
changing and things--
popular these days--
this is also another
great case to use
RequestAnimationFrame to send
up new updates to the screen
rather than putting
it all inside a
single on scroll handler.
And so that's basically
the best way
to handle that situation.
ADDY OSMANI: Cool.
And we'll be sure to show
the link to jQuery
RequestAnimationFrame at the
show frameworks, check it out.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, absolutely.
Thank you everyone
for joining, and
see you next time.
ADDY OSMANI: See
you next time.
Bye.